>>My name is Reese.
I'm ten years old.
I live in Mainer, Texas.
It's a small town right
outside of Austin.
And I like to play baseball
and play Gamestar Mechanic.
>>I really like making
games because you get
to be really creative with it.
>>Okay, so right now I'm
logging into Gamestar Mechanic.
It's pretty much the only
platform I make games on.
You can have it be a story game.
You can have it be a blasting game.
You can have it be an
easy game, a hard game.
I mean, really, you
can do almost anything.
"Graveyard Story" is pretty
good; it was my first hit game.
So your goal in this one
is the spooky-monster thing
that can transform into a werewolf.
>>When it has a good story it
comes through to the player just
like when you're reading a storybook.
>>In this one, you're
stranded in this random world
and you're trying to get out.
Your goal is to find out where
you are and get back home safely.
You have to collect all
the points and survive.
>>Man: It's great that kids who
have a natural affinity for wanting
to make games get to make games.
It's, you know, like giving
them the tools to paint
or write a book or make music.
It's fantastic to allow them
to express themselves
in the pure art form.
What's really interesting though is
if they understand
the broader context
of how those mechanics can
be used in other areas.
>>Reese: So each time I don't
want it to be exactly the same,
because then you could just toy
with the pattern eventually.
And then that way he's
difficult to get past.
>>Woman: I'd have to say that the
problem-solving skills that he gets
out of this are so
valuable across the board.
Math, physics, all of these
things involve taking a problem
that might seem too difficult
at first and then figuring
out "Which parts of it can I do?
I'm gonna start with the
parts that I can do and see
if they give me clues
to the next part."
And designing games is a lot of that.
>>Reese: And we'll just make level
two just a little bit harder.
Maybe add some more
enemies that shoot up here
or maybe have the people shoot
faster or maybe have people
who are pacing back and forth.
>>I have thought about the
similarities and differences
of baseball and video games.
I think that I like games
because they're a challenge,
and I think I also like baseball
because it's a challenge.
>>And they're challenging
in different ways, but
they make you think.
They both make you think about where
you're going to put this next enemy,
where you need to be
for the next play.
And I really like that
about both things.
>>Sometimes I look at the comments
and see what the people have said
and sometimes I go back
to change the games
so that people will
think it's better.
>>Man: One real key attribute
of Gamestar Mechanic is
that you have an authentic
audience, right?
So in most classrooms you're building
stuff for your teacher who may
or may not have time
to read your essay
that you wrote just
because it's an essay.
But Gamestar Mechanic
has a vibrant community
where people are making games
for real people, real audiences
that have real demands
and expectations.
So you have to think about "How is
my audience gonna perceive this?
How are they gonna
perceive my message?
What are they gonna
take away from it?"
And Gamestar Mechanic
has that really built in
and so that's really
key for learning.
It's something we're not
doing in our schools.
>>Reese: For comments that
say like, "This is terrible.
Make a better game next time,"
I don't take it personally.
And, actually, I kind of
laugh at those comments
because they don't help
me make a better game,
because I don't know what to fix.
But if there was a comment saying,
"I think that you need to have stairs
up here so that you can get up there
and get this," then I would say,
"Okay, now I know what to fix,"
and I would go and fix it.
>>For example, on a baseball field,
a grounder can go right
through your legs.
And if the coach says, "That was
terrible," I don't know what to fix.
But if he says, for example, "Keep
your head down, keep your glove
on the ground, and don't be afraid
of the ball," next time I know what
to fix and there's more of a
chance that I'm going to field it
than if the coach had
said, "That's terrible."
>>When I get good feedback I feel
like I can improve with that.
I can make a better game and
be a better game designer.
>>Let's try this out.
>>Man: Feedback's really
important to learning, we know.
And one of the issues with
schools that we have is
that you generally have twenty kids
going just through a teacher, right?
And so you-- the teacher
doesn't have enough time
to get in and really dig in.
Teachers want to, but they really
don't have the time to dig in
and give kids that kind of feedback.
When you have a really
robust community,
you actually have a
million points of contact.
They can actually jump in and give
each other feedback that's very
pointed, very much where they
are, and is able to be useful
for them to move forward.
>>But it turns out that
schools are kind of built
to keep these things out.
You know, our schools are very
much built to keep these twenty
or thirty people all the same
age, all the same ability area,
all the same geography, in
one room and not interacting.
What's great about Gamestar
Mechanic is that it's trying
to use the compelling idea of
games and the will and inspiration
to create to kind of burst out
and have a very vibrant community
where people are getting
together from all walks of life
around building games and
studying how do you become a better
game designer.